Oh back in the saddle ready to rock and
roll feeling pretty crappy how you guys
doing I'm only feeling crappy because I
believe that every time I fly there's
disgusting people on the plane and they
pass around germs but I'm gonna be
positive because I had myself a heck of
a weekend and I'm happy to be back
talking into your eardrums and into your
faces I was in Minneapolis I was there
for the final four I add myself quite
the weekend if I may so my say so myself
Saturday night I got to watch college
basketball with Wes Welker which is as
fun as I thought it would be I got his
phone number and I'm hoping we hang out
later and if he does a podcast it's
gonna be great and you're gonna hear it
I got to watch a game with Takeo Spikes
yes the big neck monster that dominated
back in the 90s and I'm gonna tell you
got to hang out with him afterwards got
his number might have him on the pot
let's go let's go
I'm being serious like the coolest thing
for me guys is like Jonathan Abram that
podcast I'm getting so many notes from
you guys about how much you loved them
and how great it was and the dopest
thing was when I did the pod with him I
was like they're gonna love this the 33
percent has been awesome I'm trying to
carry my 33% Turner and bleach report
working me bro working me I'm not gonna
deny it I love it man I've been wanting
to work like this my whole life so this
is great
then Saturday night magic boys and
ladies magic I'm good I'm pretty good
friends now with Travis Kelce and I got
to hang out with Barclay and all that
and I got to meet mr. Patrick mahomes
yes
I almost popped my hand up and said he's
the best quarterback we've ever seen but
you voted he's not
you voted these two I think he might I'm
just um I'm just gonna say I'm not gonna
share anything I'm not a reporter I
don't break news but I can say Holmes as
part of the 33% Pat thanks for listening
you're the man bro let's go big weekend
sauce big time weekend then I'm gonna
give you a little bit this is another
humble brag I'm humble bringing the crap
out of this bod
by the way gonna have tied down in a few
minutes tie down was the dude that wrote
the article for bleacher report where he
spent months looking into Aaron Rodgers
McCarthy Rodgers has said something
since then I just want to talk to Ty I
trust Ty Ty is a phenomenal reporter and
that's why everybody ran with this
because it's fact because Ty's reporting
and excited to have him on and then at
the end we're actually gonna have a
quick conversation with CJ Prosise
running back for the Seattle Seahawks
getting a little update on how his
health is doing and other things going
on in his life but Monday night I'm
talking like this because I'm excited
after the games are over championship
Virginia holds on to win and overtime
and anybody that watched the Twitter
show with me live appreciates you guys
go back to the hotel
Barkley goes hey Adam you're drinking
with me tonight Adam come with me Adam
so okay man you got it I'm in the lobby
with Barkley Jay Bilas Jay Williams
Chris Long shows up Danny Amendola shows
up crew status magic and it was awesome
because even though Charles was enjoying
his cranberry vodka which is his drink
of choice he still felt the need to to
tell the entire hotel pretty much how
great of a man Chris Long was and
everybody was like Cheers you are a
golden God Chris Long cuz he is
everything he does is incredible but I'd
say all this to tell you that the pot of
strong boys and girls the paw
strong the lef koe man I'm never gonna
feel myself because I love this grind so
much but just know that we're having
athletes hitting us up now trying to get
on the show that they want to be a part
of what we're doing here and the only
reason that we're able to do this
because of you guys when you guys go
into like Jonathan Abrams mentions and
tell him how great he is and how much
you like him he wants to be a part of
the show you know when you guys do this
with with Pat McAfee Pat McAfee hit me
up man he's like yeah you got great fans
you know ran gatling same thing so I say
all these stories because I appreciate
you guys for making it possible so I
just wanted to start the show with the
good energy and now let's get into the
other story that was so big I got to go
on I got to look forget Dan Patrick on
Friday ah what is going on but I went on
the empathic and I talked a little bit
about Aaron Rodgers and Mike McCarthy
and my big point was if you've ever
worked for a boss that you think you're
smarter than you understand what Aaron
Rodgers was going through I thought the
article if anything was more damning on
Mike McCarthy than it was on Aaron
Rodgers they both have come out Mike
McCarthy has denied the massages that he
got in his office Aaron Rodgers has come
out and pretty much taken shots at Ty
and at you're Michael Finley and in Greg
Jennings but I thought it was I I
thought the situation that Rodgers was
in was a lot more understanding
Nick call ty let's get him on the phone
to go over the article to go over the
response to the article because I like
you guys I'm fascinated by a reporter's
ability to work on something for months
and not let anything slip because you
know me I am more than willing to get
out there and start talking about stuff
but I've seen ty work I know his craft
and I'm just curious about how it all
came together and what the experience
was like what it's like now I mean I saw
this dude on coward getting a huge
trophy for for doing great journalism it
was pretty darn interesting but Nick's
gonna get ty on
phone but I took away from that whole
article just going if I'm Erin and I'm
in my prime I would be fed up to tie
done joining us now first and foremost
before I make this all like official and
[ __ ] ty how are you how are you man on
this on this random Wednesday
oh man I'm doing great where are you
great where are you at I'm here in
western New York it's been a fun week my
niece is a birthday party got things
started up there watch the national
championship game with my brother have a
baby on the way with the wife it's been
good week
holy crap and then the whole time your
mentions have probably been going crazy
yeah you learned to I to tune out the
noise as as a wise athlete once said all
right so what do you what are you
getting because like I was I was shocked
that I saw so many people going oh why
are you doing this to Erin and in my
head and this what I was just saying I
thought if anything it made me
understand your amazing article what
Erin was going through in that locker
room
and it felt like it was more things that
he had to adapt and he he had to be more
of a play caller and and try to lead in
certain ways to make up for that other
stuff I didn't I didn't I didn't feel
like it it felt that bad towards Erin am
I crazy
yeah you know there's there's a lot to
get into obviously but uh I think big
picture you know four months ago
starting this reporting I had the same
question that everybody had whether
you're a a Packer fan of football fan a
casual observer just what the hell
happens yeah right I mean how did it get
from the point where their offense is
doing whatever they wanted to do with an
MVP core of a quarterback and this
budding dynasty to losing at home to the
Cardinals the head coach being fired you
know yeah I mean this isn't the first
we've heard about the quarterback coach
arrest isn't the food
about that's what's so funny is I've
been hearing about this forever my
friends have been hearing about this
forever like it was like a really bad
secret it really it really was so yeah I
mean all I really did was pick up my
phone and and go through the contacts
and reach out to as many young people as
as a head in there and and new people
and you know it added up to I don't know
like I mean look here 50 50 sources in
and around the organization players
coaches Scouts I mean talking 60,000
words of transcriptions it wasn't a
wasn't about two players I know that has
been said there was a lot that went into
this yeah I think also you know in terms
of the two player let's just start there
really quick Greg Jennings has been on
TV for years now saying these things
sure Michael Finley has said this and I
I would say that if you were to have
written an article and not included
their voices it would have been you
would have been to one sided like I
thought you had to include them because
we've been hearing Jennings say this
forever
and and the reason he's saying or
whatever it's like it doesn't matter you
had to include it so I don't know why
people are harping on those two guys
when we've heard this before yeah you
know it's it's interesting I get the
criticisms and actually talked about
exactly that with Greg James when we
were having the conversation like I'm
like Greg you know what the reaction is
and he said oh I know I just want to put
my name on it because I know there are a
lot of guys who don't put their name on
it same with your michael finley so it's
weird to criticize hey I mean whoever if
it's fans like I said I haven't been
looking in dimensional yes and this
would be a team there to criticize
players who put their name on it and
also the anonymous sources who don't put
their names on it because trust me
there's a there's a lot there and I've
heard from players since the story
dropped and and look at players at every
right to just send their order back the
court has every right to define
themselves on
Twitter and that's great but you know
there's a there were also some guys
instead instead of spoken out that that
were contacted that that chose not to
talk but there's 53 guys on a team every
year there's a lot it's a lot of
personnel guys a lot of coaches and we
are you know confident in this when when
you start something like this I kind of
want to go behind the curtain with you
who do you decide to call first there
were a lot of calls yeah I was gonna say
you're unraveling something so it's kind
of like which which piece of cloth do
you pull that first you know so you just
kind of put out feelers there and then
people got back as they got back to you
huh yeah yeah yeah exactly I'd say there
was a someone in person that was around
for for a decent amount of time that saw
things up close that was the first nor
the first source that definitely shed a
lot of light and then yeah I mean things
I think you know when when Greg Jennings
is talking for whatever was an hour
might have in like 50 minutes that's in
his bringing detail lights know that
shivers telling it's one thing to hear
somebody honor off the record tell you
about the relationship or something
about the team with a quarterback or the
coach but he he was willing to show and
use examples I think also what I'm
curious from all those stories that I've
seen whether it's the massage stuff for
Rogers changing plays were ever what was
the Nugget that was said to you that
surprised you the most like what was the
part we were like wow he got that bad I
think I was most surprised at the
relationship between coach and
quarterback early on you know I was I
was out there for the 2011 season I was
covering the team for the Milwaukee
Journal Sentinel whether going 15 and 1
and and they look every bit the part of
a dynasty a team that's going to win the
Superbowl and I think everybody just
kind of a
and then and then into the next year
when they're 11 and five and there are
contender organda debt that everything
was fine in perfect between the two and
just wasn't the case
you know he's unhappy behind the scenes
he's reaching out to people close to him
he's saying that the wrong plays are
coming in with the wrong personnel and
you know even back then I think there
was sometimes confusion with younger
receivers on okay the coach is telling
me to run this route but a signal from
the quarterback is telling me to do that
and you know it's interesting that it's
like this this is it's not black and
white
it's not good guy versus bad guys Gooden
even there's so many shades of gray here
I mean you can you can see I mean why
Aaron Rodgers would run an offensive
this way I mean he was given this
freedom from his coach to to change
plays to you signals I mean he operates
not so much feel majority Nelson was
really one of the smartest guys in the
building - it's no coincidence that they
had the report they had right I mean it
who knows where the offense would have
been if he's strictly running every
single play that was called and didn't
have that freedom I think that's what's
so interesting is we've seen I feel like
a lot of stories have come out about
different aspects that were like
perfected in your story we've heard
about before Aaron being a little bit
temperamental and sensitive we've heard
about you know that the Packers offense
be talked about all the time on this
show the Packers offense being so simple
that everybody knows it's gonna be a
slant flat that maybe that he wasn't
taking it that serious yours felt like
that that great collective of all of
those things so as you as you sit back
now having covered the team are there
even things that you can look back at
back in 2011 when it was successful and
go you know what now I can kind of see
something there like does it make you
notice anything from your own past hmm
boy a little bit yeah I mean I can
definitely see where when you have that
kind of talent I mean who's gonna cover
Greg Jennings
one on one on those deep boots you know
who's going on to play action
bombs that you just saw work like
clockwork who ya gonna guard you're
Michael Finley who's gonna cover a no
clapping slot all of that and then as
that talent kind of drains and you're
kind of still doing the same stuff I
mean you're going to have you're gonna
have problems I mean a lot of the
problems between coach and quarterback
was rooted in and that the DNA of the
offense itself you know it's I think up
close is its kind of gradual you don't
really grasp it at the time you just
think like the players think and that it
just should be automatic but and then I
guess the the the head coach taking that
CEO like approach and stepping back I
mean obviously we saw the assistant
coaches always being shuffled to
different positions which is Ryan grin
kind of noted right necessarily the best
thing for the team no that's what
happened to the end of Andy Reid's
tenure he took Juan Castillo the
offensive line coach who made him the
defensive coordinator and it was like I
don't know what you're trying to do is
this like a TED talk but this isn't how
this works
granted it's you know you think these
are good coaches but it's not helping
the team if the player knows more than
the coach in that spot and then also for
the head coach to maybe take more of a
backseat role and and I run as many
offensive meetings that you know I think
that there was a perception that there
was growth for the organization through
all of that when it really wasn't
helping but I mean I mean the problems
just kind of kind of festered and and
really the fact that Ted Thompson didn't
step in and I know there's been a lot
you know a lot of a lot of criticism
toward the two people that kept coming
up in all this reporting the quarterback
and the coach but Ted Thompson as well I
mean who not see the forest from the
trees and and step in between McCarthy
and Rodgers and and talk this out or to
let all these veterans go a year too
early to lose those leaders and all of a
sudden leaders who aren't really natural
leaders are forced to be leaders I mean
that that really was a big problem how
much of this would have been fixed by
having an owner boy that's the big
question okay you know there's
definitely a lot of benefits to
not having that once things where owner
but I really do think it would have
helped at some point in this situation
too to have somebody take charge I mean
in theory it should have been said
Thompson but as we wrote I mean the last
couple years he wasn't even himself I
mean it and nobody stepped in above him
so yeah I think it would helped and I
think that's why maybe mark Murphy's
taken more of an active role when you're
about to publish this were you nervous
like what was that feeling like for you
personally going wow I've worked on this
for months over 60,000 words like what
was it nervous was his excitement what
was it like for you personally yeah you
know I think there's definitely a mix of
everything it's it's interesting there's
been a lot of a lot of folks kind of
texted me like hey how you doing this
over there and it's like I'm fine you
know it you write something like this
you report on something like this you
know it's just it's an explosive topic
it always has been so there's gonna be
that that reaction you know from all
involved and it's it's not a shock it's
not a surprise I mean we put in the
story from a personnel man you know was
talking about you know what makes Aaron
Rodgers tick and and how he thinks and
how he operates I mean the quote was
that he is super sensitive he doesn't
like people to talk bad about him he
doesn't like negative stuff said about
him it bothers him to his core it hurts
him so yeah when when they're in Rogers
every right to respond any he did and
it's it's not a surprise he should but
yeah we're it was it was an interesting
process to to talk to as many people as
we did to try to just figure out the
answer that question I can't stress that
enough I mean that's all we were doing I
mean literally everybody every doubt to
is just what happened people want to
know exactly but this and so then he
does respond and this is not some war of
words because that one that's not the
guy you are like just for like everybody
out there like ty Dunn is a is a
weightlifting beer drinking having a
good time I just like [ __ ] writing
about football like right like I feel
that's you to your core am I crazy no I
think that's accurate like I've met a
lot of writers in my life that are all
about trying to become more famous that
are all about trying to get you know
another job and the thing is about when
you work at bleacher report and you have
like a job that you have or a job that I
have where we just get to [ __ ] create
like their it like this world of like
making a bigger name for yourself is
crazy so here's the quote this is what
Aaron said to ESPN walk he said the
thing is it's not a mystery this was a
smear attack by a writer trying to
advance his career talking with mostly
irrelevant bitter players who all have
an agenda I am also saying that on this
we have in this shows Constitution that
Aaron Rodgers is the greatest
quarterback we've ever seen I said on
Dan Patrick on Friday the number one
interview I'd like to get is Aaron
because I'd like to crack that code so I
am a huge fan of Aaron and I'm a huge
fan of yours and I respect both of you
but the thing about that that quote from
Aaron was that quote sounded like a very
bitter person and and I just I don't
agree with it now I'm curious what you
thought wouldn't you saw that quote
about you yeah I obviously believe it is
an incorrect statement but like I said I
mean it's not a surprising he has every
right to get into and talk about
whatever he wants do that that's fine I
mean yeah fine you know I wasn't
offended I'm pretty comfortable in my
own skin and comfortable with every
single story I've done throughout my
career and my god no it's not nothing is
everybody's answer my career the last
thing I wanted to be a part of this
story I mean every writer in this
business doesn't want to does not want
to be a part of the story so yeah I
didn't really think much of it to be
honest if it's it it's fine it was good
to hear from him and he has every right
to think and think how he wants to think
and say what he wants to say I did think
it was interesting that when McCarthy
denied your stuff everybody was like oh
yeah no no totally McCarthy you did that
and then a rod denied it and were like
and then also I thought it was
interesting that and you don't have to
comment on this is just me doing a show
I thought that Rodgers also releasing
that he like broke his leg that first
game I was like oh that's interesting to
just kind of like controlling the
narrative and it's I don't know like
this is just for me being personal I
don't know if you can just talk from
your own experience I I've had jobs in
the past where the people that I was
listening to I didn't think were
qualified to lead and even though it's
not a real grudge you know in in your
head you go home and you're like man my
job will be so much easier if that
person could do theirs and you know and
if I ever got sat down with them I'd
look him in the eye be like look I
respect you and I like you I just wish
you were better and I feel like that's
what it felt like with air and I just
you know just as a human that's why the
article spoke to me so much like I I
really didn't think it made it seem like
Aaron was that bad right I mean that's
and that's kind of the point right I
mean didn't that's why we talked to as
many people as we did and didn't want
that lean one way or another while
trying to figure out the answer to that
question is it's not it's not black and
white I mean there's so many shades of
grey you can see and you can you can
make both cases that you know Mike
McCarthy is the head coach I should
respect authority you should do what he
says and you can make the case well what
the heck I mean this offensive stale
I've got this freedom we want to win
he's I'm all about winning like yeah
let's let's change things up and and and
play Superman a little bit like you did
because guess what he's got the best
passer rating in history so you can
definitely kind of see both both sides
here I think and in the end it's Rogers
we're out as one and now he's got to
move forward with a new coach and a
young offense and we'll see how it goes
because I'm not so sure more he'll have
that freedom that he's that he's had the
last you know what
decade from all the people that you
talked to
what is the vibe of everyone's
expectations for the new era of Packers
football with the new head coach I think
there's a lot of excitement I mean you
know another part of the story was just
how that the team really went went soft
under under McCarthy maybe the attention
to the defense wasn't there I mean there
was a player a defensive starter that I
talked you and I loved his analogy on on
that NFC Championship loss to Seattle he
said you know was like the movie the
perfect storm where yeah we're up 1600
or up nineteen seven there's four
minutes left
we're catching all those fish you know I
don't know anybody seen the movie and
but that it's bound to capsize
I think the seasons bound to capsize
because we were this this soft team with
the soft mindset and it was just
inevitable and I think that's changing I
think the fact that they went out and
they signed you know three new starters
pillars for the defense in a span of
what 24-48 hours helps I think Mike
Pettine will definitely keep that
defense moving in the right direction oh
yes why Sugar's offensively for sure I I
wish the rest of humankind can
understand that when bad things happen
good things can come from it
I just watched a Virginian suffer the
most embarrassing loss in the history of
college basketball last year and then
turn it around to a national
championship and with that being said I
firmly believe that Aaron Rodgers could
have maybe the best year of his career
next year because this is a guy that
motivates himself through criticism he
motivates himself through I it feels
like the appearance of others you know
he's not this he's not like Tom Brady
where he's like every day as a war I
must win it seems like Aaron loves a
chip on his shoulder and can I talk
about that all the time and I feel like
this could end up being the best thing
that's ever happened to him I really
genuinely believe that time it could it
really could I think and you know Ryan
grants voice
seem to get lost its got lost in the
aftermath but a man put it put it so
well you know with that double-edged
sort of okay you don't like how Aaron
Rodgers operates that way if you don't
like the sensitivity if you don't like
the fact that he still feels like he's
got something to prove and holds a
grudge and is that that rookie from cow
waiting in the green or if you don't
like that well but that that's a problem
because that's part of what makes it
great yeah you hear a lot about chips on
the shoulder with star athletes but it
is different for him and it comes up
again and again and maybe this becomes
fuel I don't know I mean it's we were
just trying to tell a story and we'll
see we'll see what happens I was talking
to him a former player recently and he
wasn't he wasn't so sure I mean he kind
of saw both points and he's like yeah I
can see where Aaron Rodgers would be
would be motivated but schematically I'm
not so sure he will want to play in a
new offense and and lose that freedom
and that is gonna be huge adjustment
period so it's kind of both right I mean
it's kind of there's a lot of
intangibles involved here but there's a
lot of exercise involved here my thing
is this though if Aaron Rodgers was an
average quarterback I wouldn't want him
to fall in line if he was Mariota or
like try Biscay where true Biscay is
currently right now yes listen to your
head coach but I would never hire a head
coach to come in and go Rodgers you're
running my system no I think part of the
reason they like Lafleur is he's a young
guy that's a very intelligent that could
go in there and go let's work together
you when you have a guy like Aaron
Rodgers you don't tell them what to do
you wait that you wouldn't go to Tom
Brady you wouldn't go to Russell Wilson
and go this is what we're doing you go
what do you feel comfortable about doing
what are your strengths what did you
love in your last offense what did you
hate and you sit down and you build an
offense that this notion that coaches
show it with a playbook drop it on the
desk and this is what we're running now
that this isn't 1980 you know I just
I don't I think if this is gonna work
it's a Lafleur Rogers partnership there
isn't a fallin line aspect to this I
agree I agree I mean it's it's a
give-and-take it's a relationship it's
it's it's okay to admit the work I just
think it's okay to admit that Aaron
Rodgers is special and should receive
special treatment because that's how
good he is
right right if you could sit down with
Aaron and not be like hey man sorry
feeling like it not like that but like
if you could ask him a question what
would you ask him about this whole stuff
boy that's a great question Adam oh I
ask kind of greg jennings head-on at the
end of the story like yeah as he put uh
a lot of a lot is made about him being
part of the problem you know as from
Greg Suhr Michael right other sources
like alright if you're gonna look in the
mirror is he is he gonna maybe make
those self sacrifice and said that are
small you know big maybe it's handing
the ball off to running backs forty
seven times in a championship conference
championship game a Tom Brady did it's
he's small sacrifice along the way
as Greg put like he can be part of the
solution so how are you a part of the
solution you know how what is that
balance and in your mind and I guess
we'll see we'll see it's gonna be
interesting
you're working on anything coming up the
next few months or and now is it sort of
let me take a step back and and and
regain my life before I jump back into
something else definitely want to jump
jump back in I mean we've got us we've
got some stories in the works here I get
the draft around the corner so well
we'll have a feature on a player how
much I'm a lot to give away yeah don't
do it don't do you know I will I will
promote it when it's dropping for sure
okay let's just we'll just roll with
that then tie you're the man dude
appreciate you man appreciate your time
man thanks a lot
always tie done
check it out Aaron Rodgers Mike McCarthy
what happened in Green Bay I know that
Aaron has come out and denied a lot of
stuff but that's what they're supposed
to do but I just think there's a few
things that we all need to think about
here if we're all in agreement that Mike
McCarthy mailed it him then why are we
going oh look
Aaron's audibly too much he's taking it
under his own control clearly he had to
clearly aaron has always been someone
that I have heard has been sensitive to
outside words he may even hear this and
go guess what I'm never [ __ ] talking
to left go which would suck because I'd
love to talk to him but how many
interview guys have I done the last few
weeks
Dante Adams Trent Brown where I talked
about using haters as fuel but just like
a space shuttle you have to drop those
heavy fuel tanks eventually or else
you're never gonna make it to space and
space isn't always success sometimes
space is peace of mind
sometimes space is contentment sometimes
it's just getting away
I think Winston Churchill called it the
Black Dog where it's like this
depression that can kind of set over you
when you're trying to achieve great
things and it's it's consuming your mind
and it could become a lot I think any
time that that people are airing things
or they're coming out and they're trying
to speak truth it's gonna make those
people feel uncomfortable because Greg
Jennings paradigm his worldview is not
the same as Aaron Rodgers Aaron Rodgers
sees the situation one way Greg Jennings
sees it another way
I think what's very funny about Greg is
he talks about how Aaron's sensitive yet
Greg is the one that can't seem to
forget the one time Aaron and I'm sure
and I'll probably say it was a joke
was like oh yeah the Vikings you guys
should sign Greg Jennings it seems
it stayed with him for a long time you
are who you surround yourself with and
Aaron seems to be someone that surrounds
himself with very intelligent people
that's what he can do if you're that
intelligent I think you can do that but
I genuinely believe it depends obviously
on the health of the offensive line
excuse me I think it depends on the
health of Aaron Rodgers and I think it
depends on Matt Lafleur legitimately
being a good offensive mind that can
build and when people compare Aaron
Rodgers to Tom Brady and they say things
like well Tom ran it like as ty was
saying ran at 46 times if Aaron Rodgers
had Josh McDaniels he would run every
play that that guy gave him but he
didn't have Josh McDaniels he had Joe
Philbin and Mike McCarthy and Darren
bevel like say those names out loud and
ask yourself if Aaron Rodgers shouldn't
have been autumn Ling all the time
Darrell Bevell I think I just call him
Darren Joe Philbin Mike McCarthy and
then you factor in what ty said when
they did make to run they had a young
Randall Cobb in the slot they had a
healthy chair Michael Finley who people
forget was like a Jordan Reed type they
had Greg Jennings able to take the top
off they had Jordy Nelson who could also
take the top off and was insanely
consistent they had a great offensive
line they good balance like everything
was clicking because they had all the
pieces and Aaron was doing whatever he
wanted I understand why Aaron has a chip
on his shoulder from the draft to having
to go to JUCO to having to sit behind
brett farr for three freaking years I
get it but I think this is gonna be
benefiting him the same way and that
story will benefit carson wentz about
people thinking that he was changing the
plays too much and that he wasn't just
he was targeting Zach Ertz too much and
not al Shawn Jeffrey
it's better to have people around you
that can tell you the truth so that you
can improve if you only have people
around you telling you how great you are
and you only have people around you
never giving you the blame you know what
happens
Eli [ __ ] Manning that's what [ __ ]
happens you end up never able to break
the cord and never able to move on the
Seahawks had to move on from their OC
because they didn't make the playoffs
the Packers had to move on from their
head coach and everybody because they
didn't make the playoffs it's time and I
think great things are in store the
other crazy story that happened over
this weekend was Antonio Brown and juju
Smith's Schuster like Wilde Antonio
Brown in this wild offseason tweet
something about you need to keep your
emotions off the internet and then
seemingly out of nowhere provoked by a
Steeler fan talking about juju brought
up the fact that juju fumbled in a
critical game and and cost them a trip
to the playoffs
juju then responded pretty much just
saying exactly what a Antonio Brown did
keep your emotions off the internet even
saying you know I got respect for
Antonio Brown and then Antonio Brown the
next day found a DM from juju coming out
of USC asking for advice and put it
online as if that were an insult to juju
what has happened is that Antonio Brown
has realized furthermore that juju was
the more well-liked receiver in
Pittsburgh and the reason is obvious
it's the reason that the 33% [ __ ] with
me because I openly [ __ ] with y'all
I'm in those DMS I'm showing up you come
to me man we're hanging out you realize
that this ain't a front you realize this
is just who I am
juju is a part of this generation he's
even more he's a Jen's heir he's not
even a millennial juju goes out in the
mall and does videos he's gonna play
video games on Twitch he's gonna do
reddit stuff like juju is out here
meeting with people Antonio Brown stays
in that mansion and doesn't need to
leave I think the reason Antonio Brown
did this if you want my left go
reasoning is because every time Antonio
Brown has called out somebody Steelers
fans have loved it when he called out
Ben Roethlisberger I don't think Antonio
Brown realized that a lot of people in
our society don't like Ben
Roethlisberger a lot the number one
athlete man if I'm at a sports bar and
the Steelers are on there someone's
taking a shot at big bet they are so
when he took a shot at his teammate Big
Ben and got all that dopamine back about
people being like yeah Antonio Browns
right Antonio Browns right he didn't
realize the dynamic so when juju came
out there and posted right afterwards
that Big Ben is still up for him and all
that stuff
I most excuse me that was awful let me
take a some water I could almost
guarantee that that's what got Antonio
Brown upset in the first place but what
an Antonio Brown is not understanding
what does shoot you gonna do
Big Ben is still his quarterback juju I
put that clip online about him going
Antonio Browns the goat and I saw a lot
of you guys tweeting at me going oh
let's see if left go still claims a B I
am NOT skip bayless I am NOT these guys
that are going
make enemies and we're gonna or that's
my guy and I'm then know your actions
determine my support and what what a bee
did to juju was dumb as [ __ ] imma put
the AF on it it was unnecessary it was
petty it was corny and I can almost
guarantee you that a lot of Steelers
fans are going to buy juju jerseys
because of it a bee secured the back the
problem with a bee is is exactly what we
were just talking about with Rogers he's
been one of the best wide receivers damn
near his whole career he excuse me now
gotten paid he's executed one of the
greatest transitions from a team to
another team from a player perspective
I've ever seen but in his mind he's
still the six round around of Central
Michigan in his mind he's the guy that
we weren't sure if he could replace
Emanuel Sanders this is what I know I'm
getting like philosophical to you guys
hate is a great fuel but you eventually
need to drop those tanks because they
will explode and and you will not be
going to space you will be a part of
space and so to everyone out there that
is using chips on their shoulder right
now that is fuelling themselves with
this it's not clean guys and it
eventually could lead to your downfall
so a lot of drama in the NFL I've always
said I want this show to bring an NBA
perspective to the NFL and focus on the
personalities but really it's been
dominated by those two stories and it
really did feel like the NBA this felt
like a burner account this felt like
that D'Angelo Russell snapchat stuff it
felt like that so thank you to tie done
coming on breaking down some insight on
what happened with the
poor you know so what he thinks with
Green Bay Rogers McCarthy
I'm hoping a be that man you find some
joy and I'm really hoping that you and
the Raiders do well because if not
Matt's gonna be a crazy season you oh
that could that can be crazy I am now
gonna toss it to a conversation with CJ
Prosise a little conversation update on
this health check in with how the the
Seattle Seahawks running back is doing
Mike Davis is now in Chicago so what's
going on in Seattle in that crowded
backfield let's listen in CJ Prosise to
everybody else love y'all homies you're
the [ __ ] I appreciate your 33% to all
the people making that reddit come alive
I'm reading it
y'all are [ __ ] great to all the
people in the DM z-- the YouTube
comments I love you a lot I am the lef
koe and a holla holla holla at you later
here's me and CJ yes exactly
that voice you're hearing right now is
CJ Prosise CJ that you song you're
hearing is from rod Simba so we have I
call them the 33% they're the homies
they're the people that listen they help
out and he was this music producer that
was like I want to make some songs for
you so he did our last theme song he did
this seem theme song they give 33% I
give 33% today you're holding down the
other 33% I got happy to have you here
man hi guys uh you're not in New York
that often I'm curious for someone that
lives in Seattle what do you think about
New York I love the big city man you
know I loved coming out here and just
feeling the energy coming from Seattle
where it's a chill laid-back you know
now I mean it's tough going on but it's
not a lot going on but you you get did
you go to New York it is we have a lot
of listeners that are in Europe that are
in different countries how do you
describe New York because I'm here every
day
I'm used to it right now what describe
it to them
I mean it's amazing I mean I love it you
know I got a lot of friends here and a
lot of people here I know but I really
just the energy is just different you
know it's just I mean really decided it
never sleeps and that's uh you get here
I mean you know I got here in here late
last night and you still you still go
get something to eat like when you get
in at 12 o'clock like or something like
that so he lets you do that Seattle no I
mean stuff kind of starts to slow down
the clock yeah ten o'clock everybody in
the house you know you know Bayona rose
after you know 10:30 11 o'clock my
number one question is how you feeling
right now
how's the body how's life I'm feeling
great feeling healthy just came off
surgery in December and you know I'm
back healthy hundred percent already 48
all right you're feeling great feeling
great so what was it what did you get
the surgery on so I had a core a core
reconstruction surgery
damn yeah that sounds intense I mean it
had had some stuff going on in there
some ligament I had 20 but I remember
reading that they were like CJ this is
something CJ's but needing to get for a
long time yeah and it was something that
was probably going on from like you know
probably started in college and you know
just been kind of kind of you know
bugging me for the whole like since you
know it really since my whole college
careers and NFL career and you know
finally you know it was just something
just happened and it was you know time
to get it done you had the surgery in
December and do you feel better than you
felt before
oh yeah I mean I feel like I'm I can do
things that you know I haven't I've been
like kind of restricted to as far as my
body was you know and now you know
getting that getting that fixed and
getting that back right you know I feel
like a new man almost bro do you know
how much that's gonna excite Seahawks
fans because like I I watched the whole
league I watch every game and that
performance against the Patriots which
I'm sure everyone's like oh man that was
the CJ Prosise game and I was like this
is this is the next running back man
like I'm excited for you that's got to
be excited I appreciate you man I
appreciate it is I mean it's it's a big
relief because you know it was always
kind of always something like kind of
felt off you know and just getting that
done you know now I'm go out there now
and I feel like a hundred percent to him
and now I'm thinking it's you Carson
penny that's a hell of a three-headed
monster in Seattle and they love to run
the ball oh yeah I mean what's that
running back room like
I mean we for one it's a lot of
competition you know that's that's
that's the best part you know we're just
gonna continue to make each other better
and you know what I mean when Carsten
him and and penny you know those guys
already they got there you know there
are run styles are so different and we
can just bring someone dynamics to the
game I'm just really excited for what
the seasons gonna be I was a very
jealous of you recently I went on and I
looked and I saw that you were at the
rock nation brunch and you were I'm
seeing a picture of you with jay-z and 2
Chainz many people I would say 99.9% of
people that are listening right now will
never experience the weekend of the
Grammys go in the rock nation brunch
take me to the moment that you're
walking in your dress fly you got the
sunglasses on you're probably a little
nervous what was that like um it's a
different experience you know that was
my first time going and you know it's
just you just see so many people who
just got just you know just so much
clout with them and there's so much you
know just so much I guess energy and
like you know just it's so much wood I
mean you just you just amazed to see
everybody and just how everybody just
just relaxed and laid back who froze you
who did you see that you literally went
oh jeez I mean I wouldn't sound really
frozen that it's okay I was I mean
listen like you know I met Jay a couple
of times before you know I mean you meet
Jay like I mean really who else you
right you know what kind of
conversations did you have with Jay I
mean you know when I first conversation
with Jay you know was just talking about
you know just just keep grinding
you know just work hard and you know you
just told me tell me how you like my
game you know right right when they
signed me son it was cool you know just
talking to Jane hearing that from him
yeah
what did you think of the outfits that
are there cuz I'm seeing people in like
the teals and the pastels listen to me
nice to st. to change that 2 Chainz came
down you know I mean a few value yeah
you know I like to keep it simple yes
that's not to chase my dream is to be
able to do what 2 Chainz does he just
walks around in a robe I'll just smoke
whenever he wants to smoke like yeah
it's to change you could already watch
he'll and they always don't always on
sports talk shows yeah doing everyone
what am i one of my really good friends
now has become Quinton Nelson oh yeah
and I'm just curious I look back at some
of those Notre Dame offensive lines yeah
I mean what were those guys like in
college I mean I was spoiled because I
mean a lot of people don't notice I'm at
my left tackle one six yeah yeah my
right tackle win number ten McGlinchey
and in my sinner win a second round yeah
so I mean you know I was I was blessed
you know I was really you know blessed
at the time my timing as far as moving
to running back and having the guys in
front of me that I had I mean you know I
had to do is run the ball
did you like did you realize at the time
that was like an NFL offensive line no
idea not at all you mean like you know
we knew we had you know at the time you
know Ronnie we knew Ronnie was the guy
right and you know cute huhuhuh came in
and we knew he was a number one guy come
out of out of college and but you just
kind of seemed cute he was yeah all
right dudes like you smell like a fire
huh he's different you're like artists
dudes like a frigerator yeah he's good
and then Nick is Zach's brother so
exactly and then McGlinchey looks like
McGlinchey looks like if you went into
the encyclopedia and looked up right
tackles Michael Ince used to be like hey
that's him right there
yeah there's a big picture of him right
there his face so and I mean and then I
write right guard we had a guy named
Steve Elmore who nobody even knows about
but he could easily went to the NFL so
how so he decided to stop playing
football so it was crazy is that you
know I had a full offensive line of guys
who just there's all NFL talents that
was a thing about you too is the
transition from wide receiver to running
back and I know that Seattle has at
times even tried you out at wide
receiver what is that what is your
relationship with the positions uh I
mean I love playing receiver and I love
playing I run it back and I think you
know I learned to play receiver and I
don't think I'm just a natural running
back you know and so the thing that's
kind of how the things like things kind
of fit together for me and then just
just my skill set that's is how I
excelled at playing both well I mean
think about the day and age of the game
right now I mean Le'Veon Bell had 90
receptions Christian McCaffrey had about
like a hundred reception it's part of
the game now that's why I'm excited when
you say you're healthy and you're
feeling great I'm going ooh
Carson's the power
back pennies like the reverse like
change a field back and then you're the
swing guy out of the back field and then
all that with this offensive line that
is all of a sudden clicking was it just
the offensive line coach like what
happened that the Seattle offensive line
went from this is a problem to now we're
pushing people well you know I think
first of all is the mentality you know
we brought back that you know we want to
bring back that running game mentality
and maybe that was something we were
kind of missing the last couple years
and then you know it came with the guys
who you know we brought in you know
Fluker and easy and it really it was
those guys who brought that mentality
back in everything and everyone came
back and then you know just when Carson
you know when Carson just pounded in
there that's that's just changed the
whole thing for us and then it just
takes it takes our whole office to a
whole new level and then in terms of
like you talked about like bringing an
identity there's been an identity change
in that team now for the last few years
where earl's officially gone Richards
now gone
Tam's gone where those were guys that
were Seattle for about a decade what do
you think that's gonna be like getting
there and they're not in the locker room
I mean look other guys are gonna step
off Frank Clark's gonna step up KJ's
back Russ is still there but how do you
think that's gonna change the locker
room I mean you know the guys like you
know the you know the players change but
the culture is still there and you know
we still have the coach the coach of the
seahawks and you know Coach Carroll
really keeps that around and we're still
gonna be the same team we still get a
hard-nosed team that's gonna be in your
face and we'd be talking trash and doing
everything to you so you know that
that's gonna be us at every game and
that's what we want to be known as and
you know even even though those guys are
gone and it was great and you know but
you know times change you know the team
we definitely move on and we show last
year that we can do do it without those
guys and we're gonna have to do it again
think about how many people had you guys
having an awful year and you go to the
playoffs
that's culture exactly it didn't go
anywhere do you know like cable thanos
like if I say that do you know what that
is cable tano's yeah
so I believe out of all the NFL teams
that Seattle has the most unique like
Internet following and cable thanos is
this guy on Twitter that
puts together all these crazy videos so
people that like crap on the Seahawks
and he like compiles it when you guys do
well and he's like oh yeah really
and it's like zoom ins and stuff yeah do
you have any experience with like
Seattle Twitter at all or Seattle cuz
like I saw you're not the biggest social
media guy yeah I'm not like a big like
you know follow it you know I kind of
look look going about yeah post a lot
you know I would say definitely post a
lot so I mean I definitely don't know
the cable Dan oh let's go do it
I know Seahawk Twitter is pretty I know
see how social media in general is
pretty faint the fan base in general was
just wild ridiculous amazing I mean
amazing and wild and crazy so you know
the twelve is there something else
alright so then I'm gonna give you some
left Co PR when you're you know you're
doing training camp and all that and
people are asking you about your health
and how you feel and all that stuff go
like shout out cable thanos cable down
cuz I'm telling you the twelves will
love it yeah it's he's there are certain
fans that are above other vas and he's
gonna them I'm excited for you I think
we're entering rendering the contract to
you right we are and you're healthier
than you've ever been and I think that's
a beautiful freaking combination I think
that the offensive line is finally
coming together
I think Russ is super comfortable right
now I think the defense has an identity
now I'm pumped for you dude like are you
feeling the energy to like what's your
mindset for the season my mindset is the
you know just go out there and do
whatever I can to help the team win you
know nothing more than that you know I
just wanna do that's awesome and
remember to shout out cable thanos okay
with ban on that guy to the 12 I won't
forget ball for hit C together man thank
you thanks for coming in